- Come on Lou.
I just need to take an
hour off to run an errand.
- Nope, I need you
on the lot today.
Even if it is a red day.
- A red day?
- Yeah you know,
your lady thing.
- My period?
- Please don't say that word.
- Why, it's just a word.
- It's gross.
- What would you rather me day,
shedding of my uterine lining?
- I'd rather you say nothing.
Maybe, I don't know,
sell some cars.
- That is what we're here for.
- Shut up Carl
And Lou, come one, my ex is
going to stop by the lot today
to pick something up and I
really rather not be here.
- Michelle, you
don't get to choose
when you come and go from work.
- Carl, I wish you
would have joined a cult
so you could only bother
people that deserve it.
- I tried.
- What have I always told you?
- People are sheep when they
come on the lot fleece them.
- No, well yeah,
but I always say, "I don't
care about your personal life"
right?
- Come on, it's court ordered,
and my ex knows it's due
today and that I'm working
so he's coming by the
lot to pick it up.
- What did you say
about court ordered?
You get caught stretching
in front of that
middle school again?
- It was one time.
They thought I was
a substitute teacher
trying to lure students.
- I mean, in their defense,
you do look like a
young substitute teacher
that is just about
to give up hope.
- Thanks.
- You two shut up.
Dan stop eating on the lot.
Michelle, you can't
go home today,
and sell some fucking
cars will you.
Jesus Christ!
Jack offs!
(Carl hissing)
- [Dan] So why you
trying to leave?
- My ex-husband has to
come pick something up.
- You were married?
- Yeah.
- You have the emotional
capability of a steel pipe.
- It was a passionate
relationship and we eloped.
- Where like Vegas?
Reno?
- No, Gold's Gym.
- Huh?
- Yeah, we were both members
and one of the zumba
instructors was ordained.
So one day after a work
out we got married.
- Yeah, that's why I
don't go to the gym.
- That's why?
- Well one of the reasons.
I also have wide feet.
- Gross.
- Like really wide feet.
By Army standards I'm F4,
unfit for military service.
- You tried to join the Army?
- Oh god no.
I hate conflict.
I just like finding excuses
to get out of stuff.
- Anyway, we got married.
I quickly realized it
was a huge mistake.
I tried to get it annulled.
We couldn't.
We got divorced and
now I'm a divorcee.
I'm a divorcee.
- So what's he picking up?
- Alimony.
- You get paid alimony.
That's the best.
It's like investing in
your sexual abilities
to the point that if
it doesn't work out
you still get paid.
- You are a human chain wallet.
He's not dropping off alimony,
he's picking up alimony.
I was the breadwinner.
I win, I always win.
I win bread.
- Wait, this guy gets alimony.
He's awesome.
- No he's not.
- Yes he is.
- No.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- He's not.
He's terrible.
He's the worse.
- No, he's awesome.
- No.
- Yes.
- No, he's not.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- No, no, no, no.
He's here.
He's right there.
You've got to give it to him.
- What is this?
- It's a check.
Give him the check and
just give it to him.
- I don't want to
meet your ex-husband.
God damn it, she Batman me.
- Yo, what's up bro?
- Hi, I'm Dan.
Can I help you?
- Yeah, is Shelly around?
- Oh hi, you must
be her ex-husband.
- Yeah, love of her life.
She blew it.
- Yeah bro.
She talks about you
like, dude, all the time.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- You know what though,
she's always worried
about her career.
Never worried about my dream.
- Oh yeah, what
was your dream dog?
- Protein shake
that's also a vodka.
Boom.
- But wait.
It's protein with vodka?
- Yeah, no, it's
a protein shake.
- Yeah.
- That can also
double up as vodka.
So you drink your protein
while you're in the club.
It's vodka with protein.
I call it Vodpro.
- Yeah, that's sick dog.
- Thanks bro.
- Sure dude.
- What do you eat bread?
- Yeah, it's delicious.
- Dude, I haven't
had bread since 1986.
- That was like, wasn't
Reagan in office?
- Who?
Reagan?
Sounds like a hot
chick I banged.
- I was talking about a
president that's dead.
- Feel my abs.
Feel my abs.
Feel that shit.
- Wow.
- Exactly.
- Really?
- I have nine abs.
- Dude, I get it.
- Yeah dude, slow
down on the bread.
- Yeah.
- Got to just go wild game.
That's what I do.
Elk, bison.
- Those are buffalo right?
- I'll eat a fucking
Native American.
I don't give a shit.
- Yeah, well anyways,
here's your alimony check.
You might want to check that.
Make sure it's all
there, she's cheap.
- Yeah, you're telling me.
I was married to
her for two years.
She never bought one
canister of whey protein.
- Dude, I've been working
with her for months,
she's never bought
me cup of coffee.
- Fucking Shelly.
- Fucking Shells.
- The worst.
- Yeah.
Hey Lou, could I
get a sales packet.
- Why, who'd you sell a car to?
- Oh, my new friend, Ty.
- You sold a car
to my ex-husband?
- Shouldn't have hung me
out to dry on the lot.
- How?
He's broke.
You sneaky son of a bitch.
You're like that trader
that convinced me
to invest in subprime mortgages.
And yeah, I did
the due diligence.
I knew it was risky.
I knew the numbers
didn't quite work,
but then I made a huge bonus
for making a smart play.
Naturally I got a
little bit greedy,
and all of a sudden
I'm responsible
for the collapse
of a hedge fund.
Can't even blame it on me.
I was just a 23 year old
who loved power walking,
yelling at phones.
- Shut up.
None of us care.
And if you keep babbling
I'm going to lose my sale,
because Ty's got the
attention span of a mosquito.
- Yeah, but you can crack
eggs on his obliques.
- Both of yous,
get the fuck out.
(electronic music)
- So what's up, you
hooking up with Shelly?
- Oh god no.
- Okay.
- I don't think anyone
could make me softer.